[Musique]
le tour de magie de vidéo il vous a plu
les amis aujourd'hui on va parler d'une
théorie encore une fois j'adore j'adore
ça ça me passionne on a commencé par
parler des reptiliens
puis on a parlé de l'intelligence
artificielle c'était intéressant en se
disant que éventuellement elles allaient
dominer le monde les petits
d'intelligence artificielle puis on a
parlé de la zone 51 et des aliens qui
sont peut-être tout peut-être pas ma
main je le rappelle tout ça c'est des
théories il n'y a rien qui prouve que
c'est vrai qu'ils prouvent que c'est
faux je préfère désamorcer une fois de
plus voilà que les gens prennent pas
trop ce truc au sérieux parce que j'ai
reçu des mails de gens qu'ils
soupçonnaient leur prof d'être un
reptilien et qui m'en parlait en mode
hyper sérieux et c'est des théories
attention les amis maintenant on a deux
pales en arrête les conneries on rentre
dans le coeur du sujet ce qui est cool
avec cette théorie c'est qu'elle est
très récente elle date de un mois bon je
voulais faire et vidéo avant mais je
pouvais pas parce qu'il n'y avait pas
encore tous les éléments extérieurs et
j'aurais su j'aurais pas pu raconter le
truc bien maintenant je peux s'est passé
ça a commencé le 13 mars sur twitter
lorsqu'un utilisateur comme vous comme
moi à partager un message vocal trouve
bizarre qu'il a reçu sur son téléphone
peut-être avez-vous suivi cette histoire
ou pas je sais pas moi en tout cas j'ai
suivi grâce à quelqu'un qui m'a
mentionné à ce moment là et qui m'a dit
'ce lucas intéresse toi à ce truc je
suis sûr tu vas kiffer il a juste il me
connaît bien et primes et ma maman ce
tome 1 paul ou julien chute on l'a
peut-être thiery bref le 13 mars
un utilisateur du nom de taille demande
de l'aide aux tweets aux pour déchiffrer
un message vocal trop bizarre qui vient
de recevoir alors ce message vocal
qu'est-ce qui raconte eva écoutons le
ensemble
n'est ce pas creepy sans déconner
imaginez vous recevoir ce message sur
notre boîte mail moi j'aurais fait comme
temps et j'aimerais partager sur twitter
j'aurais dit qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce qui m'arrive
alors les twitters sont immédiatement
intéressée à son tweet il ya eu plus de
150 milliards et sur son truc parce que
tout le monde s'est dit what the fuck et
c'est que ce bordel le message utilise
l'alphabet phonétique de l'otan c'est ce
qui est entre autres utilisée pour les
communications radio parfois c'est un
truc qui utilisent énormément surtout
par l'armée où les secours la police
pour déchiffrer c'est assez simple un
gros faut juste garder la première
lettre de chaque mot et ça te donne
d'autres mots voilà par exemple n'est
pas moi pour dire squeeze - tu dis
sierra québec uniforme
eko eko su lui il dit en écho voilà ça
fait ce que vous évoquez je vais pas
vous faire travailler aujourd'hui vous
pouvez ranger les stylos et les cahiers
taille à déchiffrer le message vocal
pour nous et ça donne danger sos it is
time for you to évacuer because you are
not your man sos danger sos ce qui en
français nous donne danger sos il est
terrible pour vous d'évacuer soyez
prudents ils ne sont pas humains
sos danger sos je change d'opérateur
tout de suite jusqu'à là on peut se dire
[ __ ] c'est un canular
ce n'est pas le seul à avoir reçu
énormément de gens dû le recevoir ça
fait peur mais voilà bon bien jouer la
blague juste là moi je trouve ça dingue
que des gens prennent le temps de mettre
au point des blagues de gens là qui font
vraiment flipper les autres quoi c'est
vraiment pas gentil du tout comme light
celle inverse d'une blague mon gars dans
le message à la fin il ya aussi une
série de chiffres et gérard une série de
chiffres c'est forcément un truc à
déchiffrer ça se balancent pas comme ça
ça signifie forcément quelque chose
alors les tweets tous ces bons tweetos
qui on flaire qui ont l'enquète dans le
sens là qui ont tous regardé des risques
et ben ils enquêtent mon gars et ils
enquêtent très très bien [ __ ] une
tweetos du nom de erin marne et 6
j'espère que j'ai cache pas son nom ça
soit un peu français je m'en bats les
couilles tombera jamais cette vidéo bref
elle a l'idée de taper les chiffres dans
google maps comme c'étaient des
coordonnées et se trouve que ça donne un
endroit très proche de celui où on a
perdu le contact avec le vol mais entre
70 de magie airlines le fameux avion qui
a disparu c'est parce qu'ils avaient
entendu parler de cette histoire c'est
un truc de malade c'est un mystère total
s'est passé en 2014 à l'heure actuelle
on a retrouvé quelques débris en 2015
mais on n'a pas retrouvé le gros de
l'appareil on sait pas ce qui s'est
passé l'histoire est très étrange et ça
normalement ça n'arrive jamais il peut
avoir des crashs d'avions mais on sait à
peu près ce qui s'est passé notamment
grâce aux fameuses boîtes noires et
surtout ça ne disparaît pas des écrans
radars comme ça là l'avion a disparu
sans aucune raison c'est un mystère
total je vous avoue j'ai pas trop
inquiété sur ce sujet là parce que j'ai
déjà peur de l'avion si je me
petit côté là dessus je vais péter un
câble j'ai jamais parti en voyage c'est
fini donc je me conserve à propos de ce
sujet mais voilà c'est un mystère de fou
pouvait enquêter de votre côté là dessus
si vous voulez et on en est donc au
point où le fameux messages reçus dans
la boîte vocale du mec est relié au vol
3 70 disparus de malaysia airlines en
2014 soit disant attention les
coordonnées sont très très proches et
qu'on incite fortement mais on sait pas
mais alors un mail du nom de rue du
maquis qui se joue en débat et qui dit
mes mecs et si le message vocal kit
avait reçu c'était tout simplement les
derniers moments de la boîte noire du
vol malaysia airlines 370 qui avait
disparu des mines
alors pour ceux qui savent pas ce que
c'est une boîte noire c'est un truc est
dans l'avion qui enregistre tout ce qui
se passait comme ça en cas d'accident ou
de crash
eh ben on la récupère et on analyse les
données pour comprendre ce qui s'est
passé et pour pas que ça se reproduise
voilà ça a contribué au fait que l'avion
soit le moyen de transport le plus sûr
du monde ya eu pas mal de théories sur
la disparition de cet avion dont
énormément qui parle d' alien qui aurait
kidnappé l'avion ou à l'intérieur de
l'avion l'un des passagers était pas
humain et voulait du mal aux gens enfin
bref alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
avec ce [ __ ] d'avion est ce que ce que
tu ailles reçu sur sa messagerie c'est
bel et bien la boîte noire qui lui a
parlé est ce que quelqu'un a pris
contrôle de l'avion est ce que quelque
chose a pris contrôle de l'avion à
internet devient fou mais alors pourquoi
les infos de cette boîte noire aurait
atterri dans la messagerie de notre ami
nice n'a rien à [ __ ] là qu'est ce qui
s'est passé l'usma qui continue dans sa
théorie des boîtes noires et dès qu'ils
étaient grosses tempêtes solaires que
quand il ya une tempête solaire
s'augmente le magnétisme dans l'air etc
en augmentant le magnétisme dans l'air
le signal aurait été amplifié pour
atteindre le téléphone de taille c'est
un peu gros comme théorie là on commence
à se dire ok on est définitivement dont
de la fiction mais ces bateaux le
lendemain elle reçoit des tas de
messages d'inconnus parce que son tweet
attire la curiosité mais de milliers de
personnes ni l'âge des screen des
certains de ces messages dont l'un qui
écrit un indonésien et l'autre qui écrit
en code morse
il va alors traduire celui qui a écrit
en indonésien et ça nous donne en
français évacués
s'il vous plaît envoyer de l'aide il y à
des prisonniers c'est l'effondrement des
nations
mais je vous ai aussi dit qu'il avait
reçu un message en code morse très connu
et le code morse est un peu chiant a des
côtés mais bon voilà quand un peu de
temps tu peux et le message décoder nous
donne they taking over soutien français
nous donne
ils prennent le contrôle toujours avec
une date la date du 18 avril 2018 cetur
pas passer aux mouches ou la vidéo sort
et et la yamaha ce jean combes si côté
contient [ __ ] les aliens arrive le 18
avril sa spéculer comme ça dans tous les
sens et taille qu'est ce qu'il a fait il
à désactiver son compte twitter tout le
monde s'est dit [ __ ] le gars il a
balancé son gros fake montée de toutes
pièces et ska comme ça vieux
conspirationnistes de merde ce mec-là
acceptait un appel skype avec un tube
heures dans lequel il a l'air hyper
sincère déjà et il dit que il s'est
vraiment pas lui qui a créé ce message
vocal il a vraiment reçu ça il est
vraiment aller sur twitter en disant
[ __ ] c'est quoi aider moi je comprends
pas c'est pas du tout un gars qui
croient aux théories conspirationnistes
de base et ses potes pareil et en fait
il expliqué qu'avec la proportion que ça
a pris déjà et recevez énormément de
messages donc beaucoup de messages de
haine du coup on est là avec toutes ces
infos à partir de là qu'est ce qu'on
fait il faut se dire que ce message
vocal il a probablement été créée par
quelqu'un qui a envoyé sa hatay taille
avec quelques milliers de followers donc
c'est judicieux en plus d'envoyer c'est
un mec à quelques milliers de followers
legasse avec de basses allait faire un
peu de visibilité et que ça pouvait
partir en gros buzz c'est ce qui s'est
passé donc a priori on dirait au final
un jeu d'énigmes et peut-être qu'il ya
plein de gens qui ont reçu le message
mais qui sont tout simplement pas sur
les réseaux sociaux qu'ils ont juste
supprimer qui sont votées les couilles
bref taille lui il a partagé et
malheureusement ça l'a mis sous
projecteurs vraiment c'est je vous ai
dit la vidéo l'a fait plus de huit
millions de vu le pauvre tout ça l'a
dépassée du coup il avait désactivé son
compte twitter il était revenu sous un
autre nom mais du coup il avait une
photo comme l'autre compte donc les gens
pensaient que c'est un fake et il s'est
repris encore plus d' insulte fin le
pauvre tout ça pour vous mettre en garde
sur ce que vous partagez sur les réseaux
sociaux
ça peut vous mener comme ta ya de très
très gros problème même un message vocal
bizarre comme ça on se doute pas mais ça
peut vraiment vous amener à de la haine
à recevoir de la haine et c'est [ __ ]
c'est triste moi ce que j'en pense je
pense que tout ça c'est un gros jeu
orchestré par des petits malins mais
très très malin parce que le jeu va
encore plus loin les gens continuent à
trouver des trucs à déchiffrer des
choses et je trouve ça beau voilà ça
fait passer le temps aux gens ça les
rassemble donc c'était pas mal
intentionnés mais c'était maladroit
vis-à-vis taille qui s'en est pris plein
la gueule
après certaines personnes pensent que il
s'agit vraiment d'un avertissement tu ya
vraiment eu une histoire d' alien dans
le vol 310 malaise airlines que tu
ailles n'aurait jamais dû recevoir sa
messagerie vocale que c'est un truc est
confidentiel
alors
est ce que vous voulez dans l'histoire
moi j'avoue je pense que c'est juste un
jeu que des gens mis au point et je
trouve ça tout aussi génial
à vous de vous faire votre avis sur
cette histoire mais voilà je voulais
vous en parler parce que j'ai suivi le
truc et je trouvais ça génial quand tout
le monde cherche des preuves à
déchiffrer les trucs tout monde se
rassemble autour de quelque chose et ce
c'est pas ça m'a vraiment fait plaisir
de voir ça ou alors les aliens arrive le
18 avril prochain pour nous exploser la
gueule merci d'en regarder la vidéo je
vous fais des gros bisous c'était génial
n'hésitez pas à aller mais s'il vous a
pu si vous voulez d'autres théories
comme ça j'adore en ce moment vous
parlez de ça j'espère vraiment que ça
continue à vous plaire on apprend des
trucs alors là il y avait pas trop de
sciences contrairement à l'intelligence
artificielle la zone 51 c'est vraiment
que des théories c'est juste l'histoire
d'un mec qui a reçu un message et je
trouve ça fou en fait que en 2018 et des
gens ils ont une vie normale
et d'un coup ils reçoivent un truc qui
sont sous le projecteur ça fait des
millions de vu tout le monde en parle
les médias relayent le truc c'est fou on
est dans une époque de malade mon gars
je vous donnerai dans une prochaine
vidéo peut-être gaming peut-être on
parlera comme là je sais pas portez vous
bien big bisous a très vite
[Musique]
ça